Tại vì anh hình là anh tạo kẻ sắp đi rồi, nằm phục lần lên đây.
Đại vì anh bắt ta rồi.
Bôi chất của mình.
Xin chào các bạn, tôi và phương anh đã lứng trên truyến tạo kẻ lịch sử.
Chứng kiến một cái khả của năm, một truyến năm tư.
Bọn ngày 1 mềm, vậy?
Tất nhiên đây là phục dựng tôi nhá, chứ khỏe đô thật đâu.
Bảo thang của anh đây, dạy khóng thật lỗi của các bạn.
Có chứ bạn.
Nói, quốc trưng đây, thà nội, dí ốc tháng ội
Nói về ngày 1 người tháng ội năm tư
Đây là ngày 1 lửa tiếp quản thà nội sau chính á khánh xến
Phang Lý Dân độ sâu ra được lý trả đó
Anh ơi, có bạn hỏi là
Châu Ân đương liệu người ta ăn mặc lý trình nào hả?
Ờ, thời đấy, thử ra thì quần hảo quần lươn xơ đâu
cũng làm gì cũng như lựa trọng đâu
nhưng mà, cái quan trọng là
thì cạo xúc trên vương mặt của mọi người
ai cũng cứ nước mắt luôn
ai cũng vui vì
người ta ở lất
ở phía chơi đợi chính năm rồi
chính năm có thể giải thống thủ đồ
có nước gản nồng người phủ đứa thì đúng với cò này
chẻ em thì cô vàng như gần quần này
mình sẽ bạnh thường mình tâm ra như mình được số mật
cái thời đấy
mình cũng tương gạnh nhau theo hết
hả sự ức?
Nhưng là Rhen Z, nhưng là thấy muốn xem thật sự rồi
rồi, ơi, em ơi
em phải đến đi
anh có thật đấy
nhưng anh tầm đồ, anh gầy, em sẽ mật thích lắm
anh tư liệu đây để liêu giữ được em
nhưng khi đi khiều đấy
và từng bà để còn có một bộ xíu tập của nhà xíu tập
muốn tánh
có rất nhiều những hiện bật trương nhân hiện tạo
quý em
và một hiện bật lệ là một câu chuyện của một gia đình thàn hội
và khiến cho lịch sử, trởi vì rất là đúng
ở
tầng bà có cổ hợp cho học sinh khó mặt
sợ cã em không nhiều
của học lắm
có vì đồng của bố học sinh
đến đây hơi hơi án nhau lắm
chúng mình ấy có con chứng chính hướng rất là kia cho học sinh
với các kẻ chình của bố với tình mưa tuổi
nhưng mà hỏi ai vào biết ngày sẽ phố mình làm
ngày bao nhiêu thì hạt nhớ
hạt biết
nhưng mà hồi đến trải không cửa đô
nhiều bạn không biết tự
nhớ nhớ
một mười tống mười, tôi nhớ một chuyện tự
hơi thì nằm nhầy
một mười tống mười của nắp hơi không phải sấu này
cho định phải đến bà cáa nước để xe lên ra không?
nhớ đây
có lâu mình
để xe hình dự xe đi, thủy hơi nhá
바 bà